Sadako Ogata was the United Nations High
Commissioner for Refugees from 1991 to
2000 the turbulent decade is her new
memoir of humanitarian action in Iraq
the Balkans Rwanda and Afghanistan next
she's joined by former NATO supreme
Allied commander of Europe General
Wesley Clark this our 15 minute event is
moderated by Washington Post staff
writer Danna priest
Sadako Ogata is president of the Japan
international cooperation agency which
for those of you do not know is the
equivalent of the USAID in addition she
chairs the advisory board on human
security a follow up of the follow up to
the Commission on human security which
he co-chaired with Nobel Peace Prize
laureate professor Amartya Sen she also
serves as special representative of the
Prime Minister of Japan on ethic Afghan
Afghanistan assistance as everyone here
I believe knows she served as United
Nations High Commissioner for Refugees
for ten years which is indeed the
subject of the book and was as she will
say a turbulent decade Independent
Expert of the United Nations Commission
on human rights on the human rights
situation in Myanmar representative of
Japan on United eights Commission on
Human Rights and boy extraordinary and
Minister Plenipotentiary at the
Permanent Mission of Japan the United
States where she previously served as
Minister prior to her diplomatic career
she had an academic career as Dean of
the Faculty of Foreign Studies at Sofia
University she received her PhD from the
University of California at Berkeley
general Clarke is again as everybody in
the audience knows one of the nation's
most distinguished retired military
officers during his 33 years of service
in the United States Army he held
numerous staff and command positions
rising to the rank of four-star general
and NATO
Preem Allied commander he's now in the
private sector chairman of chairman and
CEO of the Wesley clay cart and
associates an advisory and consulting
firm from 1997 through May of 2000
general Clarke was NATO supreme Allied
commander and commander-in-chief of the
United States European Command in this
European Command excuse me in this
position
General Clark commanded operation Allied
Force NATO's first major combat action
which saved over a million and a half
Albanians from ethnic cleansing in
Kosovo before that from 90s the the year
before 96 97 he served as
commander-in-chief of the United States
Southern Command Panama where he was
responsible for the direction of US
military activities in Latin America and
Caribbean I could go on let me just say
that he is of course a graduate of the
United States Military Academy and was a
Rhodes Scholar at Oxford from Arkansas
in 1966 two years before another Rhodes
Scholar from Arkansas who became even
more famous than a priest covers the
intelligence community for the
Washington Post and is also an analyst
for NBC News she's worked at the post
for 15 years where she was the Pentagon
correspondent for six years and then
wrote exclusively about the military as
an investigative reporter she was one of
the first reporters on the ground for
the invasion of Panama reported from
Iraq in the late 1990s before the war
began and covered the 99 1999 Kosovo war
from air bases in Europe I think you can
begin to see the connections here she's
written extensively for the post about
the nation's four regional commanders in
chief Army Special Forces training
programs overseas and the 1999 Kosovo
air war and the Army's peacekeeping
missions in Bosnia and Kosovo she was
awarded a MacArthur Foundation research
and writing grant
and she won the Gerald our Ford prize
for distinguished reporting on national
defense so you have here a very
distinguished panel let me just say a
brief word about the format after the
conversation we will open it up to
questions from the floor
please make them questions and not
statements and keep them brief so that
others can have the same privilege and
then after that mrs. Ogata will say sit
but the chairs of all disappeared we
will produce a chair for her to sit at
that table and sign books for those of
you who bought the books which are
available outside and now Donna priest
it's yours
thank you well I'm so happy to be here
at night when I was first asked to
moderate this I thought this was such an
intriguing pairing because really even
though they come from extremely
different worlds and backgrounds both
these individuals represent the two
sides of the coin which is to try to
give time for political or give time in
space for a political solution to the to
the world's crises and I've I know that
that's cause a lot of frustration too
and the political leaders don't step in
and take that space as quickly as they
should and over the years as you all
have read the military and the UN
humanitarian organizations have learned
to work together and have been thrown
together a lot of times in different
locations and that's really what I
wanted to start with a question for mrs.
Ogata is you you you go through four
scenarios northern Iraq Afghanistan the
Great Lakes region and the Balkans and
throughout that one of the common themes
you talk about is working with the
military or underneath the airstrikes of
the military or dealing with the
refugees who are in the process of
fleeing military
action so I wanted you to tell us what's
the most difficult thing about working
with the military and in in this
experience have you can you pull out
some lessons learned for how do you make
how do you make that relationship work
better thank you very much there are
moments when working with the military
is not easy at the same time I had to
work with lots of other organizations
and agencies that were a lot more
difficult to work with the military is a
very organized setup the humanitarian is
not all that organized at the same time
if the purpose is very clear clear and
we know the objectives we can work with
the military at the same time it depends
on what sort of military action is
required when the military is really
trying to contain the situation when it
the military it's easier but when the
military is in combat situation then how
do you really work with them because the
humanitarians are not in combat
situation I have to protect the victims
as well as the staff and those other
times when working with a military
becomes a bit difficult so did you
develop or do you have some
recommendations for developing
communications that can facilitate that
that working relationship I know that
NGOs and other humanitarian
organizations always have a somewhat
conflicted view of how closely they
should be aligned with any military well
I think the reason if there are the
moments when it's difficult to work be
aligned so closely with the military is
when the military tried to take on too
much of a humanitarian posture that is a
rather difficult situation but
communicating very clearly I had no
difficulty communicating directly with
the general Clarke because it was clear
the object especially over Kosovo what
the military was trying to do was to
have one clear objective what was to
have the Serb security forces withdrawal
that
very clear but when the side effect of
that action became a flood of refugees
going to Albania in Macedonia that I
think complicated my job but I'd
complicated the military job as well
because that was a side effect that was
not quite calculated and are there
lessons that you learned and your
Balkans and experience in particular
about how to make that relationship work
better and maybe even where the limits
are well first of all working with
Sadako Ogata was a pleasure and it
wasn't difficult and the reason was she
had very clear views very clear
standards she had a good strong
organization and they were always easy
to reach and coordinate with and her
people were on the ground and they were
experienced and they were often more
knowledgeable than the military people
who had just come into the theater
difficulty came in that there are other
nongovernmental organizations than the
UNHCR so as we were for you the most
difficult of all the situations was we
were running the bombing and Kosovo and
we had some non-governmental
organizations who insisted on delivering
relief supplies in the middle of bombing
runs we couldn't contact them we
certainly were not going to tell them in
advance where the targets were we often
didn't know where the targets were at my
level because they were targets of
opportunity on Serb forces and these
were trucks moving on the road and they
weren't marked and no one knew who was
in these trucks so ultimately their
movement stopped what most of the
Europeans wanted us to do which was to
take more direct action against ethnic
cleansing so how do you have you at the
same time not alert them but alert them
in other words try to get them not to do
certain things on a given day you can't
because the organization's not the UNHCR
but other non-governmental organizations
they all operate on their own drum beat
and so it was perfectly reasonable for
these I think this was a Greek
non-governmental organization they never
supported the fact that we were going to
take Mel
reaction against the Serbs anyway and
there was a certain mindset that some of
them had that they would be able to
forestall our military action by
delivering humanitarian supplies and
they were successful at doing so and so
we had to operate around that it was
just it's one more factor of difficulty
and clutter on the battlefield it's one
more reason why the application of force
can't be done from 20,000 feet
effectively in many situations you've
got to have other options you can't rely
on only a single dimension to apply
extreme pressure one of the things you
just mentioned was sometimes the concern
is that the military might take on too
much of a relief role and I know from
being with troops on the ground some of
your troops on the ground in Kosovo that
they felt pushed into that because the
relief organizations weren't as big and
as you said not as organized so how do
you make sure that that doesn't happen
and how do you try to help them so that
they can actually step into the breach
or is it possible to do that
well impossible it became very difficult
for NATO I think because you were doing
airstrikes bombing from 2020 thousand
feet is it yeah and at the same time you
wanted to show that you were doing this
for the people and so there was a
contradiction in in the poster which I
think gave the kind of signals to the
NGOs which way are you really running
but I'd like to just qualify it was not
UNHCR it was not born to work with the
military when we started this closer
relations this is because the nature of
the war had changed from being
interstate kind of wars to internal funk
conflicts in the 1990s and this was
something that was very new to UNHCR a
very good example was when we were
delivering goods through the back
through Bosnia and the UNPROFOR this is
the UN peacekeeping forces were was
undated to assist us which meant that
they wanted to to cover the convoys that
ran through convict areas and our
colleagues were very uncomfortable they
wanted to go without military escort but
when the war became one in which was
fighting between peoples and between
military all over the place you had to
have some escort to make sure that the
road was clear that there were no
attacks so while they were they were we
were delivering so gradually we had to
receive the assistance and this is how
we got to so the more serious the war
and the need to be on the ground in
conflict situation this relationship had
to be developed can you explain why NGOs
or humanitarian groups would have
problems being guarded by the military
oh I think they're because they wanted
to keep a principal position but you
know the security coverage was something
that you HCR undertook on behalf of all
the NGOs as well this was one thing as
the lead UN organization in charge of
refugees we try to help the and maintain
security information provided to the
NGOs as well this was in cost for as
well you know many of your soldiers
would complain about the humanitarian
mission I think on the one side they
liked it because it was something that
was so positive for the population on
the other hand it was not what they were
trained for how do you pass more of that
is there a way to pass more of that to
the humanitarian organizations that are
by nature smaller when you're operating
in the same area I think you're asking
key questions but let me say first of
all that it wasn't all his soldiers on
the ground who complained it was Sadako
who came to my office in the middle of
his and complained that I was trying to
do her job but there was a reason why
this had to be done because in the
Balkans the the object of these
campaigns was ethnic cleansing so the
people were forcing the people out or
retaining the people that people became
the weapons in the larger campaign so
take the case
of Kosovo first where we worked closely
together when Milosevic forced the
Albania the Albanian population coast of
all out of the capital of Christian up
by putting him on trains
it wasn't he may have said it was an
accident I don't I won't believe that
because he knew very well that Macedonia
is an ethnically balanced Society
president gligar ah've had already told
me and if he told me before the war
started he certainly would have it would
have been known in the region that he
could accept maybe a hundred thousand
Albanians more than that and a
government was going to fall at three
o'clock on a Saturday morning of Easter
weekend as I recall a date in 1999
suddenly these people started being jobs
60,000 people coming through the border
crossings there at block J in and and
Mike Jackson called me the commander on
the ground and the government's gonna
fall I'm gonna be told if I don't take
care of these Albanian refugees they're
gonna ask me to leave I called President
Gligar all that morning I sure did we'd
do what we could so it became a
strategic function of the armed forces
to take care of the refugees right then
and there
lest we destabilize our host country
there wasn't time to let it be handled
conversely in Albania what was happening
was the Albanians of course were happy
to have the other Albanians there they
expressed full political solidarity but
we couldn't have the refugees collected
and remaining in the area near the
border with Kosovo at Keuka SH because
if they were at Keuka SH they would be
targets for the Serbs and if we ever
were going to have a ground option we
wanted to have those avenues of approach
cleared out so that the Serbs would not
be able to retaliate against refugees if
NATO decided to do something militarily
against on the ground against the Serbs
to get them out of Kosovo so there the
mission was to help move the refugees
into an area that was less sensitive and
less vulnerable to
Tac so for reasons of military and
political necessity the ref dealing with
the refugees became more than a
humanitarian issue just the it's the
similar exact circumstances weren't
present and they won't be present in any
other conflict but let's take the case
in Bosnia there what UNHCR was doing was
frustrating
the Serbs intent to ethnically cleanse
eastern Bosnia it was clear and it was
well understood by the United States and
Western nations that they were asking
the UNHCR to undertake these supply
missions with the deliberate purpose of
frustrating ethnic cleansing and of
course the Serbs knew this so what the
Serbs wanted to do was do everything
they could to defeat the UNHCR without
bringing down NATO intervention or the
intervention of the great powers so
Milosevic just knew he knew just how
hard he could shake the tree before the
apples fell on his head and he would
bump it and so if you read missus oh god
his book she talks about how on occasion
their supply convoys were targeted and a
man was shot and somebody that the
airport was shot when she was it was it
was it may have been accidental in a
particular circumstance but the policy
of pushing the UNHCR to try to break
them without actually attacking them was
part of the Serb military campaign run
by general Milotic he knew exactly what
he was doing and so in this case is as
Sadako has said we were into a new
situation we weren't just providing
humanitarian relief we the Western world
we were actually one way or another
intervening to try to work against
something we find abhorrent which is
ethnic cleansing
is correct what we were trying to do was
we can sort of what shall I cover that
phase but we wanted I wanted very much
and this is when I would complain that
political action take place because we
can keep that period in which
humanitarian assistance is not just
giving goods it's about being present
among these people to show that the
people who were victims were taken care
of the international community had not
abandoned them this is a very important
message about being present but we
cannot do that forever and this is where
I think I wanted more action quickly at
the political level because negotiations
what kind of a new state of Yugoslavia
comes out that was at the bottom of the
issue and so I complained that we did
not want to turn into a humanitarian fig
leaf and that I'm afraid I must have
said that in my desperation but that
word went around you the UNHCR was being
used because the Western countries were
unable to agree and push through the
United Nations the kind of stronger
proposals that were required to bring a
political solution to the conflict this
is unfortunate but it is exactly what
happened it was it's it's what happens
when you don't have other means
available to resolve a conflict and when
the international community is split and
divided and so the United States which
had suffered its own problems at the
time in Somalia when it had put its own
force on the ground was reluctant you
know when I when I was reading your book
might it made my blood boil to see the
kinds of pressure that were that that we
subjected humanitarian workers to and we
in the West and in the United States
standing for what we stand for we put up
with it we tolerated it we failed to
come forward decisively until a mortar
incident in Sarajevo in 1995 in which we
finally said enough is enough
- Milosevic and then you know we did a
short bombing campaign and I remember
Milosevic telling us as we were meeting
with him and he's saying to hold work he
said oh mr. Holbrook you must stop this
bombing it's so bad for peace
it was bad for his version of the beast
yes but you know he was prepared to do
everything he could do - he didn't care
about the people there he wanted to bump
them as hard as he could to get them out
of there and it was a courage of the
unhcr and it's unarmed workers and their
idealism that helped prevail in that
circumstance well if you make if I made
your blood boil must have been it was
worth writing I think a lot of things in
that decade as we something you said in
the book that really struck me as you
said you know the structure of the
international community crumbled in 1990
and in in each of the countries in the
West we've had our own difficulties come
to coming to terms with this and and you
were in the front lines with your
organization because it was the
crumbling was expressed as these states
falling apart and people unscrupulous
people using force to gain their own
ends and we didn't have the political
will the consensus the strategy that was
necessary to take action but we could
all join and feel that there was a
humanitarian issue and that's why the
UNHCR and were the front lines and you
were the front line general in that
period certainly the humanitarian
agencies UNHCR UNICEF these were all on
the front lines when we called ourselves
the front line organizations but there
was a limit to what we can do and this
is what was very frustrating for me as
you understand I don't have 5000 foot
soldiers for example that's a big
difference
borrow them for a minute is that not
well it's the factor that in fact
happened in them the blotchy they in
Macedonia for example General Jackson
understood he should go in but he
understood that he should get out
quickly too and so this these are things
that happen there but at least and in
the Balkans there was focus and if I
could just express my frustration over
the Great Lakes region in Africa we
could not get even the military to
assist the humanitarians this was a
whole area in which there were no real
international readiness to correct the
situation probably seen the movie Hotel
or why I haven't seen it yet and I
haven't seen it but I lived through it I
lived through it in the Pentagon I lived
through it in my duties as a j5 I was
responsible for helping coordinate the
US response to the international
situation through the UN and its of
course we didn't know everything with
the clarity that we know it today but we
knew something terribly wrong was
happening but the United States was
recovering from the previous October in
Somalia and it had been a severe
political trauma to have 18 US soldiers
died there and it had really it had
dimmed the the bright light of
expeditionary operations in fact you
know we were talking about how to get
out of Somalia at the very time you know
we went back and someone said prepare a
plan for intervention in Rwanda we
looked at it about 20,000 soldiers a
couple of billion dollars and somebody
said we're going to go to Congress we're
going to put 20,000 Americans in the
middle of Rwanda we're going in Hawaiian
and our national interest there exactly
is what we did we didn't you see we
didn't have the strategy now President
Clinton would tell you he very much
regrets that he said that and as one of
the staff officers involved I you know I
made up my mind afterwards I'd never let
something happen like that again if I
could prevent it which is part of the
reasons we responded in Khost by the
same way but we just we it was 1994
there wasn't a strategy we didn't
understand we hadn't conveyed it to the
American people and the same things
happening in a Darfur today it's very
difficult to decide how to intervene and
when to intervene and I am not really
advocating military interventions all
the time but when there is a crucial
point when all the other means of
intervention and I would call
humanitarian assistance a way of
intervening in order to protect the
people against all the the the watch I
say war liking whether it's the
Warlord's or the militias or whatever
you have to protect the ordinary people
and for that international presence it
could be police presence it could be
observers all these things have to be
still worked out they're not enough
really intervening means of protecting
people available but at the very very
last end and I remember when NATO did
air strikes over garaged I remember that
was from that finished it and at that
time the political negotiations the
american-led one started really to have
a effect so there are times when that is
important but we shouldn't let situation
come to a point when a military
intervention is becomes necessary do you
think in Darfur now that we have to
intervene
well I think that Darfur I don't know
Darfur very well at all I have not been
there but there are some six million
Sudanese who are either refugees or
displaced and something had to be done
and something has to be done now but at
least in over Darfur
I know it's inadequate but the African
Union is trying very hard to send their
observers and I think they all help
should be given to the Africans trying
to do something about themselves do you
have in your in your mind a formula for
deciding when it is time to intervene I
get I hear this question a lot asked
them people have had a lot of experience
in this area
in Bosnia I think a little earlier
intervention might have prevented a lot
more lives from being lost in after in
the Great Lakes region yes
when see after the there was a point in
96 I think when the there there were all
the refugee camps were attacked and this
was about a million people were lost
from the refugee camps and it was a
tactic placed from the within as zyre
there was revolution going on and then
rwanda wanted to clean up there the
refugee camp so there was attack on all
the refugee camps and finally finally
the Security Council decided to send a
force and they before the force arrived
the refugees for all the camps were
attacked and the refugees were sort of
forced back at that and after that UNHCR
and a lot of the NGOs - we all worked to
rescue the people who are lost in Zaire
and I wished that the minute I would
have been more active in helping these
people out in the in the jungle I
thought it would it was very difficult
but then the the the coalition forces
decided that they had done enough and
you couldn't find any more people so
it's true concept in your mind for when
it is time how do you how do you finally
decide that how do you is every case
just so different you can't have a model
to judge it by well President Clinton
said that when you can make a difference
you should conceivably there are places
where you can't make a difference but I
think that when you look at these
humanitarian situations which are never
Humana it very seldom humanitarian that
tsunami of course is a clear example of
a humanitarian situation that had no
political overtones
nobody caused the earthquake the case
that that Sadako is describing in Africa
of course is not that way those refugee
camp
held Hutu organizations their interim
leaves were there and organized and so
as far as the Rwandan military was
concerned they were legitimate targets
they were armed they were basis of
future invasion back into Rwanda this is
the difficulty that you get into and
humanitarian operations you cannot
disarm camps and keep them disarmed
unless you're willing to put the
resource the military resources in to do
it and then to protect the people and
provide them security so that hasn't
those equations haven't been worked out
very well
in general we had the conditions worked
out for when to intervene back in 1995
and it has to do with when your
interests drawn largely not oil but
humanitarian valuations are affected
when there's when all other means have
been tried when you have the appropriate
resources and can make a difference when
you can sustain the intervention with
political support at home you go in with
an international coalition with an
established alliance if possible and
unilaterally only as a last resort and
you always do it with minimum force and
maximum diplomatic effort along the way
there were a list of eight or ten of
these criteria that we worked out and
you simply have to go through it and
apply them in every case I think one
thing though is clear about intervention
you've got to tell in a democracy you've
got to be transparent and you've got to
tell people the truth about why you're
going in
you can't hype it it has to be straight
and political leadership then has to
take the consequences of straight talk
that's a very difficult thing to do
sometimes was a general shalikashvili
who promised the Congress that you'd be
in Bosnia in just one year
so talking straight is sometimes hard
for all sides I guess
when they're trying to convince Congress
that's exactly right
it is very hard to lay these kinds of
conditions out and be totally candid and
straightforward I would say this that
the when I first heard the one year time
limit I'd missed a meeting at the White
House and somebody called me on the
telephone at home and told me oh by the
way they decided it's only gonna last I
giggled because it was clear that it
wasn't gonna happen in a year but when I
was doing part of Dick Holbrook's
negotiating team we were negotiating
with the Bosnians on this it turned out
to be a fairly wise negotiating tactic
to say we were only going to be there
one year because as far as the Bosnians
were concerned of course they wanted us
to stay forever what they wanted to say
is I you'll be here until we have
elections off we can't have elections
for at least five years
you know meanwhile the Serbs said it
would be better if NATO not come but if
you come come in small numbers and leave
quickly so setting the one-year deadline
was important diplomatically it did
convey the wrong impression initially
and it subjected the administration to
great difficulties afterwards in
justifying the continuation of the
meeting but if I could say this as one
of the veterans of that period I think
we had a better way of expressing how
long we were going to stay in Bosnia
through the matrices that laid out what
the conditions were for exit and the
quarterly tracking that we provided to
the Congress and the United Nations on
the duration of that mission it was a
more transparent mission continuation
decision process than what we are seeing
today in Iraq to ask some questions
about the current situation can
you would what do you think prospects
are for Afghanistan and how can the
UNHCR as small as it is and with so many
problems in Afghanistan hope to really
make a difference and can it do it
without a bigger military presence the
military presence will be necessary but
when you look at post-war Bosnia at the
end I think the number of peacekeepers
you had there was about 30,000 but in
order to keep the peace after the peace
agreement you have to have 60,000 people
and I think that is a very important
lesson that to keep the peace even after
peace agreement which is always fragile
is something that you have to take it
much more seriously Afghanistan I think
is not doing too badly I was there again
in December I went to not only Kabul but
also to Kandahar area there is some
dividends of peace there is some
recovery I mean 5 million children in
school is not a small thing
more than 4 million people refugees and
internally displaced have gone back I'm
not saying that they're in terror - very
very good condition not all of them but
they're back and they're trying to get
some jobs done a little bit here and
there so when you and then there is a
government that president that who was
elected that election process we all
worried there was some insecurity but it
worked and three years ago when you
think of how it was it's not doing too
bad and of course there is the puppy
question know that there's still and get
the economy now moving is a real problem
but there was enough concerted attention
international us involved Europeans
Japan was involved know that trying to
keep the security at least get the
social conditions improved for the
people these were very basic things that
I think we're moving and I hope this
kind of concerted attention would be
important too to be repeated in other
places
UNHCR really led the repatriation and I
think it's important
the first step for peace is in how
refugees start going back and this is
something a start that has to be
obtained it treasured and really
bringing about luck resources there so
war starts when people flee war ends
when people go back and there I think
UNH has very important role to play in
war and in peace sure that view an
optimism an optimistic one on
Afghanistan or I do Afghanistan and Iraq
are doable
this is not like Vietnam in either case
Vietnam we were facing a superpower
conflict the military instrument was
much less capable if we sustain our
involvement if we work if we can move
beyond humanitarian assistance into
economic development in Afghanistan if
we can get rid of the opium poppy as the
national crop and move into something
else we got a chance Afghanistan is on
strategic terrain it is a natural
conduit it has natural gas and other
resources it is prime agricultural
territory if you can bring water back
and plant the orchards that they had you
can grow wheat there there's there's a
lot that you can do in Afghanistan if
will provide the wherewithal and the
education for people to do it and yes
there are still terrorists there and
there's still the threat of Islamic
extremism there so we can never neglect
that much of what happens to Afghanistan
is going to depend on what happens in
Pakistan and that's a much more
difficult problem for outsiders to
influence as far as Iraq is concerned
again I mean the terrain the military
the demographics this is not Vietnam
it may be an incredibly difficult
problem but it's not Vietnam
I mean that in Vietnam
essentially in 1973 we left behind
inside South Vietnam the North
Vietnamese Army it was left behind
inside South Vietnam because well there
was no way to attack it and in
negotiations inevitably reflect the
balance of power on the ground we wanted
out we wanted our prisoners repatriated
and we wanted to remove this as an issue
in the American political system so we
accepted something that we couldn't fix
militarily we spent years bombing the Ho
Chi Minh Trail only to find afterwards
that it was as faulted the trees were
laced together that there were bunkers
that were virtually impervious to
anything but a direct hit from a 2,000
pound bomb we built base camps in
Vietnam at places like Koo Chi only to
find that they were built on top of a
tunnel headquarters filled with enemy
soldiers 40 feet underground beneath our
division headquarters in kuchi so I
think that the scale of the fighting the
difference between US military
capabilities and the opposition's
capability is so much greater now and
especially in that terrain that that
level of resistance can't succeed in
Iraq in other words the Vietcong were
able of the north and these were able to
still mass battalions and regiments
against us despite our air power to
everything in Vietnam there there are no
battalions of insurgents massing against
US forces we're not having isolated
outposts overrun they can hardly fire
mortars off a truck without being chased
down the street by Apache helicopters so
we are being hit by improvised explosive
devices there is an insurgency going on
it's very serious and people are dying
and it's wrong but it's principally
being targeted now in an effort to
provoke sectarian violence and prevent
the emergence of a cohesive State
I think Iraq has always been a more
doable post-conflict situation then
popular opinion here may have given it
credit for because it wasn't handled
well that having been said you know the
consequence of Iraq is liable to be a
state which is profoundly disturbing to
many other states in the Middle East
simply because of its Shiite majority
and the potential connection to Iran so
it's not clear even if the United States
succeeds in getting a stable secure
dimmer somewhat democratic government in
place in Iraq that it will be a
long-term agent of regional stability
open it for questions and when you're
thinking as you're thinking about it we
have one microphone over here but I
would like to ask you a follow-up as you
search for a hand maybe this is Oh got
it can you can I ask you one follow-up
on the Iraq question is the UN ACHC are
prepared to come in in in much larger
numbers once the violation for coming in
at much larger numbers but they were
very limited refugee outflow from the
current Iraqi situation there were
refugees who fled in 91 but in the
current situation that is very limited
there are other needs they're okay right
up in front here here he comes
so uh I would if either of you could
speak to the question or the problem of
moral hazard in humanitarian missions
that is to say for example where a rebel
group may engage an opportunistic
provocation to bring on atrocity which
will lead with intervention which will
lead to their realize that's what their
political objectives
KLA for example in Bosnia but also in
Darfur our he has the the JDM and the
SLA learned the lessons in the south of
Sudan where the rebels have gained a
seat at the table for several million
dollars a day with oil revenues and if
they succeed will there not be perhaps
other rebellions in the East Sudan you
take your pick on the exam I don't think
I know Sudan that well to answer this
that question I think there's always
efforts made by groups to play to larger
geostrategic concerns and that was
clearly the case in the Kosovo situation
and we understood it was also true in
the case of Bosnia after all had as many
people now recognize had the European
Union not recognized these states as
they begin to break up the conflict may
have followed a different pattern in the
Balkans so the humanitarian situations
can hardly ever be extracted totally
from the overlying politics and
strategic considerations in the region
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
concerned about the humanitarian
situations and it does raise the issue
of how and when properly to intervene
and I believe in what Secretary of
Defense bill Perry called preventive
diplomacy we should have our eye on
these situations long before they
explode into humanitarian crisis
we should be attempting to help emerging
governments meet the needs of their
citizens so that people don't resort to
terrorism and violence and intimidation
in an effort to provoke a
counter-reaction
in the case of Kosovo for example we
tried very hard mrs. Ogata had a UNHCR
mission there for some time in the 1990s
we also had a u.s. Information Agency
the library there and I recall when we
tried to bring this up in the in the
Dayton negotiations and the discussions
leading up to Dayton in 1995 of course
Milosevic said no this is his problem
it's an internal Serb problem it's not
the international community's business
because it was his business he was
cleaning up the situation to suit his
political aims so sometimes preventive
diplomacy can't get traction but it
should get traction and it shouldn't
only be led by one nation it should be
the responsibility of regional
organizations like the African Union or
as the last resort multilateral
organizations like the United Nations
but rest' by individual countries we
shouldn't wait until the situation
disintegrates into violence to consider
responding to what Wesley said you see
it's important now there is if there's a
moral issue you do want to go in but how
to go in and there are various ways of
ameliorating the situation I always like
to remind myself but the international
community to the Rwanda refugee
situation were 30 years old it was 30
years there were problems over the Tutsi
refugees left not being able to come
back there was a lot of violence and so
on and simply did not attract enough
attention internationally to do
something about it the word prevention
didn't really come in so strongly until
the mid 90s if I remember correctly
there was nothing or now everything is
prevention but do we really do something
about it but it's important to have a
much longer-term preventive approach
the only way to deal with all the things
that will still happen that are awful
saying just one more thought on it you
know President Bush has said that our
America's interests are our American
values democracy and freedom and so
forth our rights our Bill of Rights
I agree with that and that's why the UN
Declaration of Human Rights is so
important to the United States of
America and one of the things we need to
be encouraging the UN to do and other
regional organizations is to establish
the proper legal framework where
governments are absolutely held
accountable for how they treat their own
citizens before you have violence this
is why the Helsinki basket of Accords
from 1975 is so important that was that
laid the legal basis for dissidents in
Eastern Europe that led to the
ultimately the freedom of Eastern Europe
but that's not echoed in other regions
of the world and it needs to be and it
needs to be one of our real main efforts
if we do that right we can promote
freedom we can promote democracy we can
promote human rights and we can do it
without violence and without military
intervention
hello this question is for miss Agatha I
was just wanting to am in your present
position as president a jaiku I really
took your a very powerful voice and
Japanese foreign policy and I was just
wondering what what you think Japan's
role can be in issues such as refugee
assistance and in general human rights
one policy and what the future of
organizations like Genco might be well I
think Jack day is doing all right for
what it is supposed to do at the same
time for overall Japan was I think for
Japan it shall I say Development
Assistance is a very important form of
involvement and contribution to the
world because Japan is not a military
power and I don't think it should be it
should depan is in certain situations
trying to participate more in the
peacekeeping even within an
international framework which is alright
and may be quite useful but development
assistance is something that Japan has
done and should do more and this is why
I guess role is a very important one and
this is why I'm trying to do as much as
I can as far as refugees is concerned I
think refugee assistance internationally
internationally with UNHCR and other
humanitarian I will try I would think
that Japan will continue to be a very
strong supporter there are some problems
over the asylum seekers treatment I
think there's more of that in many
developed countries because many of the
asylum seekers are mixed with migrant
migrations movement which is very very
big everywhere in the world and I am I
could not to really as High Commissioner
really have a big impact on Japan's
asylum treatment and I hope now that
there is a little bit more focus there
are NGOs their lawyers the groups that
are very serious even some of the
younger staff of my own organ
have a lot of feel for these things more
so I hope this will develop one thing I
hope Jaka can do better is when I was
High Commission for Refugees and when
especially with repatriation and
reintegration of returning people I was
very frustrated that the development
agencies were slow in coming and I hope
the development agents world bank is
trying to be quicker these days and I
appreciate that but I hope Japan to
jakka would be a bit quicker and coming
into situation to link the humanitarian
efforts to quickly more quickly to
development assistance
have major books I don't know if
interested but certainly one of the
situations that continues to trouble the
international community is how to deal
with the affective maternally displaced
people people have been forced out of
their homes and communities for the same
reasons that refugees flee
internationally there's no one place of
the UN system or an international Armour
agencies etc that deal with this we see
it again in Darfur but the
secretary-general complained today that
only five percent of the five million
dollars he appealed for for humanitarian
assistance for people was was given and
the AU has only been able to put out
nineteen hundred and what we hope would
be three or four thousand troops so I
wonder what you think about that for
general Clarke as well surely well I can
answer this question very during my time
when the wars were internal wars I did
not see much reason in just waiting
across the border just for Refugees and
not deal with the internally displaced
people who didn't quite make across the
border so what was in Somalia we did
cross border operations so that the
refugee elite are internally displaced
would be refugees would not be a
disregarded so we did quite a bit for
internally displaced there is a
sovereignty issue which is politically
delicate in many places but the the
Balkans the the Bosnia all together we
dealt with about eight hundred thousand
refugees who went to Europe and the rest
were all internally displaced and nobody
said that I had no right to deal with
internally displaced we took care of
them just because we were in the
situation in which displaced people
whether were just internally displaced
or across the border needed UNHCR's
protection and assistance and we did
that in many places if the I think the
principle was if people were fleeing
with from the same cause across the
border but stayed inside this is
something that you and HR should deal
with and I think we extended our
protection and assistance and especially
when it gets to repatriation
you're not going to say we only take
care of people who come back from across
the board
we did and in Afghanistan UNH cert did
affirm repatriation and reached
integration for internally displaced and
refugees and that's what the government
wanted to so I don't think there are
certain what shall I say
man mandated the differences and some
insisting that - UNH I has no right now
no if you look at situations UNH air has
done a lot for internally displaced and
should be doing first of all I agree
with you that we should not have an
artificial distinction between those who
cross borders and those who are it's
still a humanitarian crisis and no one
wants more than the soldiers that I know
of so nobody has any greater
humanitarian instinct than they do they
want these people to be taken care of it
breaks our heart when we're in these
operations to see the suffering of the
civilian population so anything that can
be done should be done I'm sorry that
there weren't more troops that were
donated though in this mission that
you're mentioning it's it's unfortunate
that with hundreds of thousands millions
of people under arms in the world we
can't come up with more than 1,900
troops for this problem but it
underscores the importance of further
action to strengthen the United Nations
to enhance its credibility and
legitimacy and to give the United
Nations and other international regional
organizations the capacity to help keep
the peace and deal with these
emergencies in their regions what I said
I don't mean that UNH I should deal with
every displaced persons everywhere in
the world
well maybe it's a resource problem if we
have the resources I think we should at
least there's the expertise and the
understanding but mobilize others do the
same but especially if there's a link
between the internally displaced and the
refugee I think definitely UNH I should
to extend its mandate
are there questions over on the side
this question is actually for both I was
like to answer it from what the
humanitarian military perspective you
spoke earlier a lot about what it's
right to intervene and General Clark
misspoke about eight or ten criteria
that you usually run down and I was
wondering can you both address when it's
right to disengage and what factors help
you to decide what it comes right when
it's right it's right to disengage my
impression was that the military
disengaged a bit quicker than the Amana
terian that's before you in before you
and engage usually discuss about when
you disengage may be for political
reasons as you've said from now but
especially oh this was the experiences
maybe because of the experience we had I
had over the Great Lakes region
disengaged was something that you can do
only when there was nothing no more
refugee so in turn this place to help
and there was no we did disengage from
Zaire at one point because there was
nothing we could do anymore
and then we disengaged so our
disengagement is much more practical and
how much we can still do for saving the
refugees or the internally displaced if
there's something we can do we should
not disengage well on the military side
it's a strange paradox or maybe it's not
so strange but you want to use the
minimum amount of force but normally
when you're intervening you're
intervening because there's some
underlying political problem now the
tsunami of course is it's not that case
but in the Balkans and Afghanistan or
wherever else there is an underlying
political problem it's up to the
diplomats to take advantage of the
present presence of the military forces
to resolve the underlying political
problems that led to the conflict the
internal disintegration or whatever
in the first place you take the case of
Kosovo today that has not been done the
international community has for years
said it would make a decision at some
point on a final status for Kosovo and
how to get there and it's still being
resisted the frustration of people is
mounting in Kosovo and it it's going to
precipitate the kind of violence which
will be embarrassing to the UN mission
there and the NATO forces who remain on
the ground it'll be deadly to some of
the people are engaged it'll set back
the the peace process so it takes not
only the intervention of elements on the
ground it takes active political
leadership in nations capitals who are
willing to put their public reputations
on the line to deal with some thorny
issues and to use the presence of the
international agencies in the military
forces to resolve the underlying
political conflicts if you don't do that
the forces get stuck there and then you
have the risk of conflict reigniting
that's Kosovo in Bosnia the problem is
internal corruption and that we still
haven't resolved ultimately the problem
of the war criminals and and other
conditions there which lead to the
tension and the separation of the of the
communities in every case has its
particulars but the general principle is
get to the bottom of what caused the
political breakdown in the first place
take advantage of the presence of the
forces brought on by the humanitarian
crisis to resolve the underlying
politics if you don't you'll be back
Liberia is the case in point just let's
imagine for a moment that you were
president
would you would you back a separate
independent Kosovo at this point I'd
back a process that takes it that way
that has that as an ultimate conclusion
but you know people have to be treated
fairly we're not going to replace one
kind of ethnic cleansing with another
and sanction it with the international
community that's flat wrong that's why
the NATO troops have been dedicated to
trying to protect the Serbs that remain
in Kosovo the religious artifacts the
monasteries and so forth that remain
there and they've done a job that was as
good as they could do under the
circumstances it hasn't always made me
and other people happy we haven't
succeeded in every case but we should
have but you know our frustration the
military's frustration there is that we
need some political help you know we
could do the protection a lot better if
the political leaders and capitals would
move this process forward I think it's
clear that it's going to be very
difficult to reintegrate the almost two
million Albanians that are there into
Serbia and I think the international
community should face that as a reality
as much as we dislike creating separate
states in this a case where a decade of
cultural imperialism and ethnic
cleansing has precipitated and and made
final as the sort of irreconcilable
political breach that's only going to be
healed by giving people a greater sense
of responsibility for their own futures
but the international community can't
endorse that until their treatment of
minorities improves in that country so
you've got to put a process in place but
you have to put that process in place
you have to have a goal in mind and you
have to be have enough courage to
articulate the goal and there are many
who don't want to articulate that goal
so that's why I say I support a process
and the articulation of a goal but
independence right now No
this question is for general Clarke and
it has to do about NATO over the past
decade NATO is obviously taking an
expensive role and now you see NATO
troops in Afghanistan you see him taking
a larger role an advisory capacity in
Iraq and even talk of them playing a
greater role in the Middle East and my
question to you is in two parts
do you believe NATO has limitations and
what do you believe those limitations
are and do you believe that the model of
NATO as a political military
organization can be replicated for other
regions of the world
well I think NATO what you have to think
about NATO is NATO is a consensus engine
think of it this way it's a it's a
machine it's got cranks on it and you
put thorny issues in the top and you
turn the cranks and every nation that's
in there cranks these issues out and out
comes a little piece of paper it says we
agree at the bottom and sometimes it
takes a week sometimes it takes six
weeks or six months to get that to turn
those cranks and get that agreement out
but we can NATO is a political
organization since it if you can get the
agreement politically it's not just to
put forces in somewhere it's to work
together to have the desired outcome
whether that's to encourage peace and
the Balkans or peace in the Middle East
or whatever it's important so NATO is
the primary instrument that links the
United States and Europe right now after
all to two countries are a group of
countries cannot have any tighter
relationship than if they pledge that an
attack on one is an attack on all or a
threat against one is a threat against
all and essentially that's what the NATO
Charter says I you know you're saying
are there geographical limitations well
certainly there are geographical
limitations because there is only so
much military resource to go around
there's only so much attention to go
around there's only so much political
will to go around
but I think if you look at the United
States and ask what's our role at this
particular time in the world well we are
the only superpower right now China of
course is a growing country it promises
to be very powerful country in the
future but it's not there yet
India is going to be another very
powerful country in the future they're
not there yet what the United States
should be doing is in addition to
protecting our own security is we should
be trying to help other regions of the
world evolve into greater compliance
with law greater respect for their own
people conformity with UN principles and
we should be building an international
system in which the rule of law is the
norm both in relations between states
and in how we treat citizens within
States that's a world that's safe for
Americans to live in and grow up in in
which our values are secure we could
have no stronger ally in this pursuit
than the Europeans and we have NATO as
the consensus engine to link us so we
should take that consensus engine as far
as we could go we should have with the
Europeans and understanding that will
never do operations alone if we don't
have to if we can do them through NATO
through an alliance that's the
appropriate way to go
yes it's harder to turn the cranks on
the machine it's a lot harder to get 26
nations to agree to something than it is
to run from the Pentagon across the
Potomac to the White House and sit
around with ten people in the Situation
Room and say okay that's it it's done
don't forget on the way out somebody
call the Speaker of the House and tell
them what we're going to do I mean this
is if this is a lot different but it's a
lot more effective in most cases if we
will use an alliance it's not a weakness
of the United States it's a strength
that we can lead this alliance and we
should do so they're looking to us for
leadership but you know leadership is
not just telling people it's not like
hey I told you what I wanted and you
didn't do it so you're not a good ally
it doesn't work that way
I mean that's not what a leadership is
leadership is dialogue it's to give you
you know to put it in real concrete
terms in the 1830s a British minister
said this he said Great Britain we have
no permanent friends only permanent
interests and you know fifty years later
an enlightened Russian diplomat repeated
it in a hundred years later the F Genie
prima coffee said it to Soviet diplomats
when he was the prime minister he said
remember this Russia 1998 has no
permanent friends only permanent
interests Hey look that's 19th century
balance of power of politics in an
interdependent world we can't live that
way we must turn that axiom upside down
in the United States and in the world
today we have permanent friends and we
must make our interests converge that's
the task of leadership and NATO's a
great instrument to do it with
up in front here
so I have one questions for both general
clerk and missile gathered first of all
I would ask Jennifer out that I don't
know third nano-air champion coastal
Western Reserve Security Council
resolution so do you think this campaign
can be a president to make a new rule to
establish the International raw human
humanitarian intervention and next I
want to ask miss organizer you say that
before intervention using after force
all this is actually all available piece
group options such as a diplomatic or
Portugal option have to be exhausted so
but do you think at the very last moment
that it is no no peace group options do
you think the military using material
options can't Chancery should be
permitted to protect several people
markets to recall that that you did not
get a Security Council resolution to go
into Kosovo and in essence does that
create a new model they should be used
in other areas and to mrs. Ogata if
everything else fails and military
intervention is the only alternative
should the military be limited to
protecting civilian protecting very
options they actually managed to use
okay so let me answer the question sweet
it's true we did not have a UN Security
Council resolution that said it's okay
to bomb start bombing and one of the
reasons we ended up in the position we
were in is because the Serbs knew we
would never be able to get that kind of
a resolution I can't prove it but it's
my belief that this information may have
been conveyed to them by the Russians or
some other power during the summer of
1998 it was like okay the Americans are
flying aircraft they're making threats
about stuff don't worry you're never
gonna have to get it worried about a UN
resolution that authorized it we'll
never authorize them to intervene in
your problem like that and then what we
did get though was a chapter 7
resolution that authorized all available
means to be used to address the
humanitarian crisis and it's ambiguous
but in the way that the UN works and
people understood it all available means
means military force so it was a sort of
sliding in there wasn't everything we
wanted but it was there in addition
there's other precedent for military
intervention in previous international
cases and we did go to the highest
organization we could go to once the UN
channel was blocked
we tried diplomatic action Tremblay and
then we went to NATO and it was the next
lower organization to get NATO
resolution was it everything we wanted
well of course it wasn't technically
everything we wanted what we wanted was
a UN Security Council resolution but we
couldn't get it and we knew it was
simply unobtainable and so we did that
States did I didn't do it but the
presidential and prime ministers made
these decisions they were elected
representatives they made the decision
that rather than allow the Balkans to
disintegrate in chaos and once again
see repeat of Bosnia and wring our hands
and throw missus or goddess unarmed
humanitarian workers in there and have
all this going on again that we would
stand up and take responsibility and do
what had to be done
preemptively to prevent a regional
destabilization caused by another round
of ethnic cleansing in the Balkans is it
everything we wanted legally no but it
was an action that was undertaken that I
was personally glad that we undertook
because I think it saved a lot of
people's lives in the long run well I
think what the discussion is really over
situations in which there is a great
deal of human suffering miss
mismanagement by the state itself over
their citizens there is a very
humanitarian crisis it exists and this
is the context in which I would I was
arguing that for last resort
military action may be necessary and you
know that when you look at the Balkans
especially without the last resort being
used I don't know how much more lives
would have been lost and how much that
would have been prolonged you see there
is a real dilemma over a genocide for
example genocide is is a very special
kind of killings it's a systematic
termination of a of a race or ethnic
group but when do you say that there was
genocide and you can intervene do you
have to have 1 million people killed
before you work on that I think there is
a dilemma there if there are general
cycle events going on you should
intervene not necessary by forcefully
but by very much more stronger
international presence international
humanitarian presence Human Rights
presence or even police in that kind of
law-and-order presence and at the very
end if that doesn't work I think as a
humanitarian I would have to say yes I'm
not talking about warfare it's really in
these situations of gross violations of
human rights and a lot of loss of lives
at Iraq as a last resort that may
be necessary I hope it doesn't have to
happen all the time but I happen to have
lived through situation in which I
cannot say it was wrong I think I'll
have one time for one more after that
it's related to the humanitarian
organizations disengagement in my
understanding there is also a transition
of humanitarian organizations role which
is not only classical distribution of
food or making camps but also like
reconciliation or reconstruction of
societies after refugees return on such
as UNHCR's quick impact projects so
could you briefly mention - the kind of
new role of international human tere
organizations well I'll be happy to do
that you see this is the role when more
when peace is emerging when there is
warfare in the at the midst of ethnic
cleansing you cannot talk about
reconciliation or being practical but
when the peace is emerging today most of
the peace is not really clear peace
agreement but it's emergent peace and
you have to build the peace people
return a quick impact project that UNHCR
I think devised took place in Central
America in the 80s but now it's coming
back as a very useful tool but we also
try to work on one kind of
reconciliation problem UNHCR has always
had a role in defining reconciliation
amnesty in peace processes but a much
more positive one that we devised and
try to promote was one called
imagined coexistence because this came
out of my own experience in our
colleagues experience how difficult is
for people next door that your former
neighbor coming back after you killed
each other's families that kind of
situation so it was really trying to
make them live together again having
common jobs job needs because you have
to survive in order to
that you have to work and to work you
have to work with your former enemies so
this kind of reconciliation work is
important there is something that
addresses much more justice transitional
justice kind of situation is also
working towards reconciliation I think
there is a lot of need for
reconciliation that many scholars and
NGOs and it are all focusing these days
that is part of the peace process which
is really kind of peace building or
state building and that model is comes
out of a lot of conflict situation
within communities and UNHCR has tried
to develop this in many places and I'm
sure there's a need in many other parts
of the world today as well
thank you my question is mr. Ogata to
general crowd mentioned the importance
of Regional Human Rights institutions
but AGOA region doesn't have one and I
know that what happened power model
tiger or Japan this time it's for the
Asia region but I think it's a system
has been divorced from the human rights
aspect so I like to ask how so we repeat
the question just general color
mentioned regional human rights
organizations and institutions but Asian
doesn't have one how do you evaluate
well Asia is the least regionally
organized region it's not just Human
Rights security now it's moving more
towards free trade zone that kind of
thing is happening so for various
reasons and I won't go into that is the
least regionally organized place and
that has been recognized and there's
some talk no even the sixth power
negotiations may lead somewhere but this
is a reality as far as Japan's and
economic assistance is concerned yes
Asia well it was concentrated on Asia
and Asian countries many of them have
have developed economically and so right
now I mean using Jacquizz budget I would
say some 30 more than 35 percent of our
budget went goes to Asian countries
there especially the Indochina route
countries are late in development so
there's concentration there and so in
comparison only about 15 16 percent goes
to Africa but now there is a clear
recognition that Asian countries with
their economic achievement are now also
wanting to be a assistance giving
countries and so we're trying to be
partners with the Asian countries that
are in that one Malaysia for exam
Oh Thailand - they're all wanting
they're all starting to be development
assistance countries for Africa I want
to increase that to more than 20% of our
budget and this is happening so there is
a shift important thing is we meet the
needs of the people and this is in Japan
we'll be shifting and I will hope Japan
would also increase or stop the decrease
about yay okay thank you very much
Sadako Ogata was the United Nations High
Commissioner for Refugees from 1991 to
2000 she is currently president of Japan
international cooperation agency in
Tokyo the turbulent decade is published
by WW Norton & Company on the web at